hey this is Steve with data lab welcome
to the course I'll be your instructor
and the guy responding to any comments
or questions that you might have as you
work your way through the lessons the
goal of this course is to give you a
solid introduction to building skills
for Amazon elects and to do that in a
way that makes sense even if you've
never written a line of code before in
your life so there is absolutely no
prior programming experience necessary
however to make the best use of our time
I will assume that you're familiar with
what Alexa is from a user's perspective
and that you have just some basic
computer skills the course is broken
down into a collection of short videos
most of them are under 10 minutes but a
few are a bit longer
also for some topics I'll be referencing
related videos and resources that
complement this course and for those
I've included links in the course notes
finally all of my demos are going to be
done on a Mac but if you're using
Windows or Linux you should be able to
follow along just fine okay I am sure
you are ready to get started so that's
it for my introduction in the next video
we'll take a look at how Alexa works
from a technical perspective and discuss
what you'll need to get started as an
Alexa developer
the jumping-off point for getting
started with Alexa development is the
Alexa developer portal and it's located
at developer.samsung.com slash Alexa to
get started you want to spend some time
browsing through the public content
there and which you'll quickly learn is
that Alexa is way more than just the
brand and the brains behind the Amazon
echo Alexa is also a service from Amazon
that makes it possible for anybody to
extend Alexa's capabilities or
incorporate Alexa into smart devices for
developers the Alexa service provides
the Alexa skills kit and the Alexa voice
service the skills kit lets you add new
capabilities to make Alexa smarter and
these are called skills
so if Alexa doesn't do something now
that you'd like her to do you can teach
her how by creating a new skill the
Alexa voice service on the other hand is
used for adding Alexa to new devices or
software so for example if you wanted to
create an Alexa enable toaster you'd use
the Alexa voice service to do that our
topic is building skills so we're going
to talk more about the Alexa skills kit
the skills kit is a collection of
resources to make it easy for developers
to create skills for Alexa skills kit
includes documentation software
development kits application programming
interfaces and example code we'll be
taking a look at all of these in more
detail using the skills kit is free in
fact in most cases you won't need to pay
to publish build or host your skills and
nothing that we're going to be doing in
this course should cost you anything at
a high level there are two things that
you need to do to create skills you need
to create a voice user interface for
users to interact with your skill and
you need to build a skill service that
provides your skills functionality the
first part is done through the Alexa
developer portal and doesn't require any
coding but it does require an
understanding of how Alexa works from a
technical perspective and we'll be
covering that building the skills
service is a bit more technical and does
require some coding however even if
you've never coded anything before in
your life you can build a basic skills
service using Amazon Web Services fairly
easily we'll talk more about building
skills services in a minute but first
let's
take a closer look at the skill set up
skill configuration settings and what's
referred to as an interaction model tell
the Amazon Alexa service about your
skill and this lets the Alexa service
know how to recognize when users are
requesting your skill in the
functionality that it provides new
skills are set up through the Alexa
developer portal at developer diamas on
comm and when you setup a new skill you
define how users enable and interact
with it and how the Alexa service will
communicate with your skill service to
provide your skills functionality the
developer portal is also where you would
submit your skill to be published in the
skill storm we'll talk more about the
publishing process later on your skill
service provides your skills
functionality and this is code that
you'll write to take action on and to
respond to user requests Amazon doesn't
care how you create your skill service
you can use any programming language and
technology stack as long as it can
properly communicate with the Alexa
service that said the easiest way and
the recommended way to build a skill
service is by using Amazon Web Services
or AWS
and that's what we'll be doing so to
wrap up let me summarize how Alexa works
with a custom skill so first a user
speaks to an echo or an Alexa enabled
device and the audio is streamed from
the device to the Amazon Alexa service
next the Alexa service converts the boys
stream to text and determines if the
request is for a skill by looking at
skill configuration information that the
developer sets up in the Alexa developer
console if the request is for a skill
the Alexa service sends the request to a
skill service that the developer created
to provide the skills functionality the
skill service takes action on the
request and generates a response that is
sent back to the Alexa skill service
through the Alexa skills kit API
from there the Alexis service responds
back to the user okay so that's it for
our high-level technical overview in the
next video we're going to jump right in
and create our first skill
[Music]
okay now we're gonna jump in and we're
gonna start building a skill and we're
gonna take this process and break it
into the next couple of lessons to
provide a high-level overview of the
process you can step through this as I'm
going through it if you want to do that
or you can just kind of watch the
process to get a sense of what's going
on we'll be building a custom skill
later on but for this lesson in the next
couple of lessons we'll be just walking
through one of the skill examples or the
example skills that Amazon provides to
just get familiar again with the setup
process and kind of how everything is
working like we talked about in the last
lesson
there are really two main parts that a
developer needs to worry about when
they're setting up a skill the first
part is configuring the voice user
interface and the other part is
providing the the code or the
functionality that is gonna process and
respond to requests that come in through
that interface by users and the the
first part of that creating the voice
user interface is what we're gonna take
a look at in this lesson and then we'll
talk about the back end which is the
skill service in the next lesson so the
the starting point for setting up a
skill is to go to developer dynamics on
comm and set up a in Amazon developer
account if you don't have one already in
Amazon developer account is free so you
don't have to pay for anything you just
sign up I'm not gonna walk through the
signup process just because it's pretty
straightforward the the only point I'll
make on the developer account is that
you probably if you have an Amazon echo
set and you're you don't need to have an
echo to do Alexa development but if you
have one you want to use the same email
address with your Amazon developer
account that you used for the account
that you set your echo up with and the
reason that you want to do that is
because if you're using the same email
address or same Amazon account for both
your developer
account and your echo then you'll be
able to test your skills with your echo
which is kind of cool even while they're
in development you don't need to have an
echo to do alexa development so if you
don't have one no worries will there's a
really nice test set up in here so you
don't have to have a Amazon echo to do
that but if you do then you want to use
the same email address once you have
signed up at developer dynamics on comm
go ahead and log in I'm already logged
in and then you would go to your Alexa
councils and then skills and this is
gonna bring you to your list of skills
you don't have any then you'll see
something like this mine is empty right
now and you're gonna start by creating a
skill and you're gonna provide a skill
name and we're gonna call this one space
fax and again this is a this is an
example skill that Amazon provides and
we're going to start with that to talk
through what's going on so I'm going to
enter the name and then select the
default language that the skills going
to use and in my case it's us English
you also have support for different
dialects of English Australian Canadian
Indian and UK English and then German
Japanese and French as well right now
and then you choose next and you choose
the model to add to your skill and this
is like the the skill type and we're
going to be working with a custom skill
type right here which is the most
flexible of these skill types is where
you're going to get the the most in
terms of capabilities that you can
provide as a developer these these other
types provide sort of more specific
functionality that's outside the scope
of this course we're going to be working
with the custom skills so you want to
select that and then choose create and
this will bring you into the skill
configuration area
and the there's there's a lot going on
in here we're gonna talk through we're
gonna talk through all this it looks
intimidating when you first get in here
but it's really not that bad once you go
through it at the at the high level what
you're doing here is you're providing
information that is going to be used to
train the alexa service to recognize
requests for your skill and for the
functionality that your skill provides
and that's all done through instructions
that are provided in what's referred to
as an interaction model and we'll go
through that in more detail a bit later
but that's what's happening in this
section here the other big part of what
we're gonna do when we're set up into
setting up the skill is tell the skill
how it's gonna communicate with the
skill service which is the backend code
that's actually gonna provide the
functionality we're not going to talk
about that in this lesson we'll do that
in the next lesson but that's done in
this interface and then also from within
here you are able to test your skill and
we'll take a look at that after we get
our skill fully set up and you can
provide information to get your skill
certified and launched in the Alexa
skill store here and then once your
skill is live you can get metrics on its
usage over here in the measure section
so we are going to set this up using a
template like I said or some example
code and we're going to get that code
from github comm so if you go to
github.com slash alexa you'll want to
find the sample node fact skill here and
in here if you go to models and then
you're gonna pick the language that is
the right language for your skill in my
case it's this english US and then I'm
gonna just copy this so this copy and
then we're gonna go back over here and
we're gonna just paste it in here so I'm
the Jason editor and I'm just pasting
that in so this is going to create the
interaction model we'll talk about this
and in a lot more detail later in the
course but for right now we're just
going over the high-level steps but the
interaction model is what's used to
train the Alexus service the machine
learning for the alexa service on how to
recognize when your skill is being
requested which is done through this
here the invocation name space fax which
we could also set through the graphical
user interface here so anything that's
done in the graphical interface is
really just editing or changing this
this jason here that you can also see in
the jason editor and the the intense and
which are what the functionality your
skill provides and then how that
functionality is is is gonna be asked
for by the user so uh pterence azure
samples here and again we'll go over
this in more detail but at this point
once we've got our our model in there
and saved we can build the model and
building the model is what trains the
machine learning that's part of alexa
and so depending on how complex the
model is this can take a little while so
at this point we've got our basic skill
set up and the model building and the
next thing that we're going to need to
do is tell the skill how it's going to
communicate with our skill service and
we're going to do that in the next
lesson
[Music]
now that we have our skill set up the
next thing that we need to do is we need
to configure the endpoint in the
endpoint is going to tell the skill how
to or the Amazon service how to contact
and communicate with the code or the
service then we're going to be creating
to handle the requests that come in from
users and so in a high-level again
what's happening the flow if you recall
from the technical overview a user
speaks to an Alexa enabled device the
device forwards the audio stream to the
Alexa service the Alexa service takes
that audio stream and converts it to
text and then determines based on the
interaction model what the user is
requesting or the machine learning
determines what the user is requesting
and then if the request is for a skill
the request is sent from the Alexa
service to a skill service in the skill
service is code that we are going to
create as developers to process the
requests that come from the Alexa
service and in turn respond back to the
Alexa service with instructions or
responses for how the Alexa service
should respond back to the user the
important point here is just to know
that everything is going through the
Alexa service so the requests coming in
from the user are going first through
the Alexa service from the Alexa service
to our skill service and then from our
skill servers back to the Alexa service
and back to the user the skills service
can be hosted by really any any web
server that can consume or understand
the requests that are coming in and
there they're just Jason requests if
you're not familiar with Jason it is the
it's an acronym that stands for
JavaScript object notation this is Jason
actually so it's um it's a text format
and it is structured in a way that makes
it easy for computers to work with and
because it's text humans can see
going on also but basically a message in
this format goes back and forth between
the Alexa service and the skill service
and so the end point here is configuring
where the Alexa service is going to send
those messages and where the Alexa
service is going to get responses back
from those messages and in our example
we're going to use a service that's
provided by Amazon Web Services called
lambda AWS lambda and so we're gonna
select lambda here and then the AWS
Amazon Web Services this is actually
different from the developer the Amazon
developer console so you're gonna need
two different accounts you'll need one
for the Amazon developer console which
we set up already the Amazon developer
account and then another for our web
services account Amazon Web Services
account and this one is when you sign up
you will be prompted for a credit card
but there is a free tier so even though
you've got to provide a credit card
nothing that we're doing in this course
is gonna cost you anything again we're
using this lambda service here which
provides a million free requests per
month which is way more than you're
going to need for this course so no no
worries about that but you will need to
provide a credit card so I thought I'd
mentioned that I'm not gonna walk
through the signup process here either
because it's pretty straightforward but
once you have an account you would just
go ahead and sign in and you would go to
the lamda service so if you just search
for it here it'll remember down there
and the lamda service allows you to run
code without setting up servers and
managing servers and all of that stuff
so it's really great and simple to use
for the most part let's you just focus
on your code and not all of the
infrastructure stuff that is not not the
the main thing when it comes to writing
code and creating services the let's
just jump in here and go through it so
the the service
you go in to create a lambda function
you're gonna create the code a couple of
different options here you can either a
function from scratch and we'll take a
look at doing that later in the course
but you can also use blueprints or the
server this application repository and
these are like templates for setting up
back-end services that are hosted in
Amazon Web Services and that's what
we're gonna use for our example here so
if you select the server list
application repository and then just
filter by Alexa and the let's see is
skills how to we are looking for the fax
skills this one right here so the Alexis
skills kit nodejs back skill and this is
the one that provides a random fact
which is the back end to what we grabbed
from github in the last lesson so we're
going to go ahead and select that and
you can leave the defaults here and then
just choose deploy and once it's
deployed I'll show you what we what we
get here it's still deploying loading
our resources
and there we go all right so now we can
go over to the skill that was created
the lambda function rather that was
created and if we click on the lambda
function we can see the code that was
provided as part of that template here
so this is JavaScript the programming
language here no js' and when you create
lambda functions you actually have the
option of using a variety of different
programming languages c-sharp go Java
Python and node.js which is a runtime
environment for JavaScript which is what
we're using here and so we'll we'll talk
more about the the code a little bit
later on but you can just browse this
and see kind of what what what's
happening this one again is an example
that's gonna give a a random space fact
so one of the facts is a year on Mercury
is just eight days long to make this
work
this is this is important here this
trigger
so the Alexa skills kit the alexis
service is not available in all regions
so if for whatever reason you run into
issues here or you don't see the trigger
added you want to go up here and you
want to make sure that you're in the
well it doesn't need to be the US East
region the US East region does support
the Alexa skills kit for sure not all of
them do a lot of them do but if you have
any question and you just want to get to
a region that supports the skills kit
for going through these steps you can
just select US East because I know that
one does and then the Alexa skills kit
is going to enable the Alexa service to
call this function and so we are going
to now just need to configure our Alexa
skill so that it can access this
back-end skill service and we're gonna
do that by copying this up here which is
a unique identifier for this function
that's called an AR N or an Amazon
resource name so I'm just copying that
and then I'm going back to my developer
console so at developer Dynamis on comm
and to the service endpoint and I am
just going to paste that in that
endpoint to that lambda function and if
it's all in there I can just save here
and it's saved so at this point I have a
complete skill set up I've got the skill
set up in the developer console I've got
the interaction model in here that I
copied and pasted from the example on
github and then I saved the interaction
model and I built it and the build
process is what trains the Alexa service
to recognize a request for this skill
which is named space fax and it will be
invoked using that name also space fax
and then we configured the skilled point
to the skill service and so now we can
go ahead and test and this is where
we're going to leave off for this lesson
in the next lesson we'll look at testing
and talk a little bit about the testing
process
[Music]
once you've got your skill completely
set up the next thing you want to do is
start testing it and like I mentioned
earlier if you have an Amazon echo and
you set up your developer account using
the same email address that you set up
with your echo you can start testing
your skill using your echo by simply
enabling the test right here so when you
do this you're also enabling the skill
under your account again if you're using
the same account that you used when you
set up your echo or the same email
address and if you don't have an echo
like I mentioned earlier you don't need
one because this test simulator here it
provides everything that you need to
test the skill so we can use this just
like we would use an echo so we can say
Alexa open space fax
here's your fact earth is the only
planet not named after a god all right
and that pulled the fact from the skill
service that we set up and I can also
test in here using I could submit my
input using text also so like open space
fax
[Music]
like this here's your fact the Milky Way
galaxy will collide with the Andromeda
galaxy in about five billion years okay
so my skills working right now I want to
just point out a couple of things here
so this is Jason input and Jason output
here the input is the input that's going
from the Alexus service to your skill
service in our case that lands a
function that we just set up so the
Alexus service is generating this and
sending this to the endpoint and then
our skill service our lambda function is
reading this taking this in and
responding with this here the the Jason
output and this is what's going back and
forth between the Alexa service and the
skills service all the time there's a
Jason message like I mentioned earlier
and the skill service is reading that
message and acting on whatever the
message is saying that the user wants
and sending a response back the the the
one point here I want to make is really
about when things don't go right when
you're testing so let me let me let me
show you kind of a case where things
aren't working so right now everything
worked and we got a response back that
the Alexa service could understand but
if you're having problems you you might
not get enough information over here to
know what's going on so let's let's
create a problem like that so I'm gonna
go over to my and over here to my lambda
function and I'm gonna just modify this
so that it generates an error that that
the Alexa service will not know what to
do with so I'm gonna change this to just
making this change again just to
generate an error to illustrate a point
so now when I go back over here and I
test I'll say open space facts there was
a problem with the requested skills
response and so this time because my
skill service didn't respond was
something that the Alexus service knew
what to do with the Alexa service is
just telling me that there was a problem
with skill service but the Alexa service
doesn't know what the problem is all the
Alexa service knows is that it didn't
get a message back that it knew what to
do with and so I just get a generic
error message which if you're getting
that and you don't know how to go about
figuring out what's going on can be
pretty frustrating it so what we're
gonna want to do if something like that
comes up and we're we're not getting
into in this lesson deep into the code
and debugging and all of that stuff but
I want to touch on this because it's
important and we're gonna need this as
we start building our own custom skill
well what we're gonna want to do is
we're gonna want to simulate the request
that's coming from the Alexa service to
the lambda function and use the
debugging in lambda to try to figure out
what's going on and to do that it's
pretty simple you would just copy an
example of the request that's coming
from the Alexa service which you can do
by just copying the JSON input here and
then you want to take that over to your
lambda function and there's actually a
test way to test right in here so you
can do this test here configure test
event and I already configured this one
I'm gonna do it again just to show you
you would just paste in give your test a
name and I called the this one launch
request you can call it whatever you
want and then you would just save it in
there if I didn't already have this this
button would allow me to save and then
once you saved your test you can submit
the test and then when you submit the
test you will see the error message here
with a lot more details and actually you
see it down here
well so you can use this information to
debug what's going on
and again this lesson is not about
debugging as much as it is just
generally how you would approach testing
Alexa skills so we'll come back to this
as we start modifying code a little bit
later on but we would go about debugging
our skill service in the lambda manager
in the AWS console and we could from
here figure out what we know what's
wrong with this because we created the
error but we could figure out more
easily because we have information to
figure out what's going on and we can
debug it there and then when we go back
of course it would it would be fixed or
we could retest it in here so that is a
just a quick introduction to how you
would go about testing we're gonna need
this as we're developing our skill
especially when things go wrong which
they will from time to time as you're as
you're building stuff so you want to
know how to go about debugging it in the
next lesson we will dive into the code a
little bit and look at modifying the
code and with this debugging lesson we
can do that hopefully confidently
because if something goes wrong we'll
know how to fix it so we will jump in
that next
okay now that our skill is set up and we
know how to go about testing we can take
a look at the code and the make some
changes to our skill service code so the
code that we we have here again is just
an example that's provided by Amazon and
the example is written in JavaScript
because we're using nodejs and we're not
gonna dive deep into this right now but
I do want to point out a couple of
things so when you're in the the lambda
editor here there is a pretty nice code
editor that you can use to edit this
code and you can expand it and if you're
working on more complex skills you
you'll probably want to use a local code
editor for but for what we're doing this
is this this is great and you can see
all the code here make changes to the
code here and the the files that are
associated with the code in this case
here we've got because this is no js'
we've got some node modules that are
included in node modules a reusable code
and the notable one here is the the ask
SDK and the ask is the alexis skills kit
SDK and it is a module that makes
working with the requests from the
alexis service really simple so rather
than having to write code to decipher
what is in that jason message that's
coming over and to generate a jason
message going back the alexis skills kit
sdk provides methods that make that
really easy for us to do without writing
a whole lot of code and we'll talk about
that more in a later lesson but for
right now let's just look at making a
couple of simple changes in here and
then i want to talk about the the
relationship between the code and the
the interaction model because that's
that's pretty important so for starters
making a change that goes back to your
user through the alexis service is just
a matter of making a change to your
skills service so in this case
here you know here's your fact if I just
change this to here's your cool fact and
save it save up here now if I go over
and test here and just say open space
facts
[Music]
here's your cool fact despite being
farther from the Sun Venus experiences
higher temperatures than mercury so the
change that I made is immediately
available for the user so any changes
that you make in your skill service the
Alexa service is going to use whatever
the skill service sends back and
provided that the the response is a
format that it can use it will be good
to go the the part that is a little bit
more involved is figuring out what the
Alexa service is sending over and
mapping what the user wants to a code
function that can handle it and that is
done through the interaction model and
so I'm gonna talk through what's going
on in a little bit more detail in the
interaction model and how that relates
to the the code and then will will in
the next lesson we'll go through some
examples of using that but first I just
want to talk through it so the the
interaction model like I explained
earlier is is it's basically
instructions for training the machine
learning that is behind Alexa so that it
can understand requests from a user that
are requests for your skill and
functionality that your skill provides
so in the interaction model and I'm just
looking at the the Jason editor here
which you can create the entire
interaction model just in code like
through the Jason editor like this the
the key pieces that you want to
understand are the first the invocation
name and we set up the invocation name
through the visual editor
or actually well we copied and pasted
this in but the invocation name is the
name that the user is going to use to
invoke or start the skill and then in
addition to starting the skill the skill
provide functionality and and
functionality is referred to as as
intense or requested functionality is
identified and referenced as intense
it's a better way to say I think so so
an intent is what your skill can do and
it maps to what the user wants and what
the user wants or is requesting is
derived from utterances the things that
a user says and so we provide along with
intense we provide samples of things
that a user might say to tell Alexa how
to recognize when the user wants
something specifically that our skill
provides and there are two kinds of
intents there are custom intents and
that is what this get new fact intent is
and then there's also built-in intents
and built-in intents we can we can add
and some of them are required like these
ones are required but built-in intense
our default functionality that is part
of the the Alexus service and so for
example the ones that we're looking at
here like the cancel intent recognizes
when a user is wanting to cancel a
session with a skill and help is pretty
self-explanatory but is gonna recognize
when a user is asking for help within a
skill and so these built-in intents here
are kind of ready to go you don't have
to provide utterances for them in some
cases you can extend their their
capabilities with additional utterances
but it depends on the the intent there's
lots there's lots of different built-in
intents in fact take a look at that real
quick so there is a library of lots of
different
from you know types of musics artists
and you know all kinds of things so
Alexa can recognize lots of different
things that a user would say even
without you having to train it how to do
that and so the the next part of this
though is is how the intent maps to
functionality that's provided by the
skill service so at the high level flow
we've got a case where a user is going
to open up a skill without providing any
other information other than the fact
that they want to open the skill we did
that in the test here when we said open
space facts and in that case they're the
message that was sent over was let's do
that here's your cool fact Jupiter has
the shortest day of all the planets okay
so in in this case here all we did was
ask the Alexa service to invoke the
space fax skill in this next example I'm
gonna ask for a fact and this is here's
your cool fact a year on Mercury is just
88 days long so in the example of this
skill it's it's pretty tough to see the
difference because the response that we
get back is the same we get a random
fact no matter what we do but if you
look at the requests here so in the
first case the requests that came in to
the skill service if you look at it is a
launch request and and this is how our
skill service knows that this was a case
where the user was just opening the
skill up and not doing anything else in
this example here the request came in
but I asked spacefacts for a fact and
the Alexa service
recognize that in this case the request
was for a specific intent and that
intent was the intent called get new
fact intent in the way that the alexa
service was able to determine that this
utterance was for this intent is because
of the samples that were provided and so
if we go back over here and look at our
get back intent you can see the the
samples in here and so the the utterance
the things that users say i are going to
provide the information that the alexa
service needs to determine what it is
that the user wants in a really simple
case the utterance is just going to map
to an intent and it will be enough
information to tell the alexa service
and our skill service to execute
whatever our code is going to handle
that intent in some cases however
intense need additional information from
the user before they can be fulfilled so
this get new fact intent isn't an
example of one but let's say we had a
skill where a user could order a pizza
in that case we would need to know the
size of the pizza the toppings the
delivery information and the parameters
size topping those things are referred
to as slots so slots are parameter
values that we need to fulfill intents
that are extracted from an utterance and
we'll get into this in a more detail
later on so this is just kind of
high-level talking through the these
pieces and so minimally you will have a
launch request where all the service
knows is that the user is invoking your
skill you can have a launch request that
includes an utterance that would not
just tell the
service that you're trying to launch a
skill but it would also provide
information to map the request to an
intent and then in some cases you'll
have intents that require additional
information to be fulfilled and that is
information that is held in parameters
called slots and then the the other
point on slots is you can provide slot
information as part of an utterance and
a launch so if I had an intent that was
to order a pizza I might say and let's
pretend my invocation name is you know
pizza skill I could say Alexa tell pizza
skill I want to order a pizza
and that might map to my order intent
but my order intent might need to know
what toppings I need so if I didn't
provide any slot that would be filled
for toppings the intent would respond
with okay what kind of toppings would
you like but the user might also say
Alexa ask pizza skill to order a pizza
with pepperoni on it and in that case
I'm getting an utterance that is not
just mapping to the intent but also
providing information to fill the slot
and again we're going to come back to
this because we're going to use it as an
example so right now I just wanted to to
talk through it and that information
slot being rigged the the intent being
requested and the slot information is
all going to get passed as a part of the
request and we're going to need to
handle that as it comes into our skills
service and the the Alexa SDK is going
to help us do that
we're going to go into that and
walk through an example of creating an
intent that has a slot and passing that
slot information over to our skill
service and responding in the next
lesson
so in the last lesson we talked about
intense slots and utterances now let's
take a look at actually using them in
our skill service code and we're gonna
start with the interaction model so
we're gonna create a new intent in here
and then we're gonna wire it up so that
we can respond to the intent in our
skill service so I'm gonna create a
simple custom intent called the hello
intent and I'm going to add some sample
utterances I'm gonna start with just
high in hello so when a user says hire
hello
I want this intent to be the intent that
response so I'm gonna save that right
now and I'm gonna start this model
building we're gonna come back and we're
gonna test in just a minute here but
while this is building let's take a look
at our skill service code so I'm gonna
use this space fax skill that we've been
working with and hack it up a little bit
here but I can use this as a starting
point because it has the Alexa skills
kid SDK and some sample code that we can
work with so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna just copy and paste for starters
so I'm gonna copy this handler that was
set up to get a random fact and I'm
gonna change this change the name of it
to the hello handler and the first part
of this code what it's doing is it's
taking in the Jason that is being sent
over by the Alexa service that's this
handler input value here and then that
is down to this next line here that is
being used for a piece of that object is
being used or an object from within that
object the request object is being used
here is this constant named request if
we're to keep that but this
next piece here is saying to use this
handler when the request type is a
launch request which we don't want to do
we're already doing that down here for
the get new fact and we'll leave that
the way that it is for right now but
what we will change here is what happens
when this intent is is requested by the
user and so we're gonna get rid of this
stuff here because we don't need that
anymore and we're gonna change this for
now we're just gonna say below like that
and we're gonna get rid of this also
this is writing back a card in the Alexa
companion app but we don't need that for
this example okay so now we've got a
handler that is going to look at the
input that's coming in from the Alexa
service and if the input request is an
intent request and the intent name is
onna not get new fact we want to change
this to something different we'll say
we'll call it the hello intent because
that's what we named it okay so this all
looks right all we need to do now is
come down to the bottom here where this
section that says exports handler and
then add request handlers and we need to
add this new request Handler that we
created in here just like that
and then we can save it and so now if
now if we look at the code and just step
through it again what's gonna happen
when the request comes over is the this
handler is going to look to see if the
intent request is named hello content
and if it is then this is gonna respond
with just hello really simple right now
so let's go back over here to our
developer console and a logged out log
back in and let's test this out so tell
space
till space fax hello so it worked so
let's look at the input here so the
Jason that was sent over to the skill
service from the Alexa service you can
see here in the request section here the
type of the request was an intent
request and the intent name is hello
intent and the interaction model is what
was used to generate this we created the
interaction model so that the Alexa
service could understand that when a
user says hello that we want the hello
intent to handle that and so when this
gets sent over to our skilled service
over here our skill service code now
is able to recognize that and respond
back with hello so that is the those are
the steps for setting up the interaction
model and then handling the requests in
the skill service now let's take a look
at what we would do to pass a slot value
over to our skill service and the steps
pretty similar so we want to go back to
our interaction model again and we want
to go to the slot that we just set up
our hello intent slot and now we want to
also include not a slot but an intent
our hello intent intent and we want to
add a slot to it so I'm gonna say my
name is and then in curly braces add the
name of a slot that I want to use as a
placeholder for a value so I'm adding
that right into my utterance
so my utterance is my name is and then
curly braces name and when you do that
you'll see down here they
the slot with the name name gets added
and then you just need to set a type for
the slop and there is a slot type for
names specifically first names and I
think there's also surnames and last
names but I'm gonna use for this example
Amazon u.s. first name here so now this
built-in slot can recognize first names
and pull those out of the the utterance
so I am good to go here so I'm gonna
save that and I'm gonna build the model
here okay and while that's building
actually I'm not gonna change the code
until this is done building because I
want to I want to show you something in
the intent requests first that we're
going to use to to know what to code in
our skills service and this is kind of a
pretty common wait at least that I do it
so I'll once I make changes to the
interaction model I'll generally test
first to see what the intent request is
gonna look like and then you just make
sure that the inner the Alexa service is
doing what it's supposed to be doing
with the with the user utterance so I'm
gonna go over here and just test this
out so tell space fax
my name is Steve and let's make sure
that it works so what I'm doing to make
sure that it works is I'm looking at the
Jason input and this again is what the
Alexa service generates to send over to
skill service and if I come down here
into the request I can see that the
hello intent is the intent that I'm
wanting and that my utterance here with
my slot in it is also being recognized
here so I can see now in the there's a
new slot section down here and then the
name name is the name of the slot and
the value is Steve and that's what I'm
looking for when I'm testing now what I
want to do is I want to respond back and
use that value so I'll say like hello
Steve or whatever the value of the slot
is when it comes over and to do that I'm
going to go back over to my skill code
here and I'm just going to say respond
back with so the input handler here is
the object that's going to the object
that's going to include everything
that's in the Jason request so I can
sort of navigate this object by looking
at the Jason that's coming over so right
now I can see in the request object
I've got intent and slots and then name
or value name here and then value here
so I want intent slots name and value to
get this so back over here I can go
request intent name
how you slots right slots not name not
value and then if I save this just
double check so request intense slots
name value and just confirm over here
intent requests ten requests in ten
slots name value okay so now if I test
this again my name is Steve hello Steve
okay so this time the response is using
the value that was sent over for the
slot and so just to recap what what we
did here so we set up the interaction
model with the intent and we added a
slot to the intent and we included the
slot parameter as part of the utterance
so that when the user makes a request to
the Alexa service the Alexa service can
identify what intent the user wants and
also extract the the value of the slot
in this case name so that it can be
passed over to the skill service and
then once we pass it over to the skill
service or the Alexis service passes it
to the skill service we can use it in
our skill as part of the response and
this was a really simple example in a in
a more complete example we would do
things like check for slots that aren't
filled and if they aren't filled and we
need the value then we might respond
back by prompting the user with a prompt
to the user for the the slot value
things like that but for right now we
just wanted to step through the the
process of using slots and setting up
intents and using them in our code in
the the next lesson we're going to step
it up a bit
and we're gonna look at coding using a
local editor and the Alexa skills kit
command-line interface and so up to this
point we've been doing everything in the
browser which is fine for what we've
been doing and fine for simple skills
but as you as you get to building more
involved skills it becomes harder and
harder to work in the the web editor so
we're gonna take a look at a local
editor and talk about the Alexa skills
kit command line interface next
[Music]
you
in doing we've done through the browser
we set up our skills at developer dammuz
on comm through the browser and we set
up our skills service through AWS and
lambda also using a browser and being
able to do everything in the browser is
really nice however as you get more
serious about building skills you're
also going to want to know how to build
skills from your local computer and that
is what we're going to talk about in
this lesson and to do this there's some
software that you're going to want to
have and I'm going to talk about the
software that that I use and sort of
your minimal requirements and then we'll
look at it a little bit and move on from
there
so first you're gonna want to have a
code editor and there are lots options
here and there's not necessarily a right
or a wrong choice as long as you can
edit text in code it will work the one
that I use and then going to be using
for the rest of the course in the demos
is one called Visual Studio code and
it's free it's open source and it's
available for Mac Windows and Linux it
is supported and provided by Microsoft
so the documentation of support is
really really good which is one of the
things that I like and there's a great
community around it so there's all kinds
of plugins and themes and all kinds of
good stuff so I like this one a lot like
I said before I mean there's lots and
lots of editors out there so this is
certainly not the only one but the one
that I'll be using for the rest of the
course and my my my preference this is
Visual Studio code here and one of the
things that I like about Visual Studio
code is that it has an integrated
terminal so the the the command line if
you're a Mac person then you might be
used to this and this is the same thing
so I can the commands that I can run or
I can run down here and that is
integrated into Visual Studio code and
the the terminal also works if you're a
Windows user and you use the Windows
command line you would have access to
the command line here and this is
important because a lot of what we'll be
doing it
you'll be doing is you're building
skills will involve using the command
line because the other tool that you're
going to want to have is the Alexa
skills kit command line interface or the
ask CLI in the ask CLI is a tool utility
that allows you to create manage and
deploy Alexa skills and that means
everything that we've done through the
web browser can be done from the command
line as long as you have the ask CLI and
so let me let me show you what I mean so
here I've got the Alexa skills kit CLI
installed and I'm not gonna walk through
installing and configuring the software
in this course but I'll leave a link out
if you go to a develop comm slash learn
I'll leave a link there to a tutorial
that I did that walks through setting up
and configuring your your local
environment so the Alexa skills kick
command line interface mainly and again
I'm not gonna walk through that here so
as I'm going in and doing this stuff
I've already gone through and set it up
and configured it with permissions that
allow the CLI to push my skills out to
my Alexa council and also to AWS but
with the Alexus skills kit CLI installed
i can go ask new and this will prompt me
for the name of a skill if i want to
create one it and let's say i want to
create one called hello world it's gonna
create a skill project which is this
folder over here and in the skill
project I have everything that I need to
deploy and create a skill both the the
skill configuration information for the
developer Alexa developer council and
also the lambda function and so here's
the lambda code there when I did this
ask new it provides some boilerplate
code when you do that it's sort of like
a hello world skill and I'm not going to
go through the code yet I'm gonna do
that in the next lesson but let me show
you just by doing this how easy it is to
deploy the code from your local computer
out to the Alexa skills Council and
lambda so you would just from the
directory that you're working in you
would go ask deploy like that and now
what the ask CLI is doing is packaging
up the skill deploying it out to
developer Nadia amazon.com first
building the interaction model next and
then last it is pushing the the lambda
function out to AWS and so this takes a
minute for this to happen but what
you'll note here is that everything is
done from the command line I don't have
to go and log in through the web browser
at all to do this once it's set up and
configured and that is a huge benefit
just in your workflow editor making
changes to skills and republishing them
and testing them and you can actually
also test from the command line here as
well but let me go out and just show you
what happened we'll start in the
developer council just by doing that now
if i refresh now there's my hello world
skill that was just created using the
ask CLI
and if I go out to AWS lambda or
aws.amazon.com to my lambda you can see
that there is also a lambda function
that was created for my skill service
and I could edit these here because all
the code is here and I could edit the
skill over here just like we did in the
earlier lessons but I don't need to do
that anymore because I can make all of
the changes that I want to make locally
I can edit the code here and I can edit
the information as well again in the
next lesson I'll go through and kind of
walk through what what's going on in
here and then I can just do deploy again
and all of my changes will be deployed
so it's a much much better workflow as
you start working on especially more
complex skills and making changes and so
that again is what I'm gonna be using
going forward in the next lesson I'm
gonna spend a little bit of time going
through this this code here just to get
you familiar with what's going on and
then I'm also going to show you how to
get some sample code that you can work
with to to start understanding and
building your own skills from so that we
will talk about in the next lesson
okay we're gonna pick up where we left
off and we're gonna take a look at the
code that the ask CLI creates and how we
can modify that code to make changes
that we push out to lambda and to the
Alexa Developer Council so ask new when
we ran that command we got our hello
world skill and the if you look in the
skill project this folder here you've
got a few things here you've got a
folder called lambda and this is where
all of the lambda code is in this
actually this custom folder here and so
if we looked at the lambda function in
AWS actually let's do that over here and
our functions here and this is the new
one that was deployed if we look in here
you can see the files and node modules
and all of the things that are here get
deployed out to here and so that is
what's in this custom lambda custom
folder here and then the interaction
model which is in the developer console
let's refresh this so in here so the
interaction model here is this here so
we can change the we can add intents and
slots and all of the things that we've
looked at previously change the
invocation name the default invocation
name for this is greeter so we can
change all of that here and then last is
the skill manifest or the configuration
information which is this skill dot
Jason file and this file contains
settings for all of the additional
information
that you would have about a skill so
things like the public name and the
description keywords all of that can be
added to that skill dot jason file and
you can use that to make all of your
changes so you don't need to login to
the developer council through the
browser to make changes or logging you
don't need to log into AWS to make
changes to your lambda function so it
makes sure again your your workflow just
a whole lot better let's let's make a
couple of changes just so we can take a
look I'll just make us a really simple
change here so the default name is hello
- world which is the name that I gave it
when we set it up and I'm gonna just get
rid of the - I'll just say and
capitalize these so a hell of a world
like this so small change of course I
could go through and edit the
description testing instructions example
phrases all that but just to illustrate
the point I'm not going to do that and
then the interaction model change it to
my greeter and I'll save that and the
lambda function will just make it change
to this it says when we opened it up it
was welcome to the Alexus skills kit you
can say hello and i'm gonna just change
this to welcome to the course you can
say hello so I'll save that and so we
just made a few simple changes and now
when I go down here and do ask deploy
again and it's gonna go through the same
steps it's gonna deploy the skill
information first and then it's going to
build the interaction model next and
this takes a little while building the
interaction level just like when we do
that through the developer council
through the web browser that takes takes
a minute and that's what's going on
right now and then once that's done the
last thing is it's going to deploy the
lambda code out to aw
and once that's done we can go test it
you can actually test right from the
command line too we're gonna go into the
the web browser just so we can see the
see the changes it's almost done here I
think okay so now let's take a look so
now if we go out here and refresh this
we can see the change that I made to the
name just remove the - not a big change
and then also if I go over here to build
and look at the invocation name you can
see that it's changed now from greeter
to my greeter and then the last piece
we'll see if this is finished deploying
it is so we'll go over here and we'll
test it and see if we get our new
greeting so we'll just say open my
greeter welcome to the course you can
say hello so there's our change so you
can see the workflow for making changes
and updates when you're working with the
ask CLI and doing everything locally is
just really really simple and that's
what we're gonna be using going forward
I want to show you one couple of other
things about the ask CLI specifically
how you can use templates so the the
default when you do the ask new command
the default template is that HelloWorld
template and/or the greeter template
which is a little bit like a HelloWorld
template but if you do ask new and then
- - template there are some other
templates that are available from Amazon
that you can use as a starting point -
so this buttons color change or template
city guide decision tree fact which is
the spacefacts template that we looked
at previously a RSS feed newsfeed
template and
and high-low game how to pet match quiz
so there's a there's a bunch of them
here that you can use as starting points
and we're gonna take a look at a couple
of those in the next lesson and we're
gonna look at modifying a couple of
templates so that they work is a really
good starting point let's for right now
just take a look at the fact one because
we looked at that before so let's see
what happens
oh you know what I did I didn't move out
of my when I created this I was still in
the hello world folder do that again and
we'll do this fact
okay let's delete this
and this is our space facts so the code
in and this one is actually a little bit
different than the default code that you
get when you use the blueprint or we
didn't use the blueprint but the the
repository version but you can make the
changes here again and deploy deploy
this if you want to if you want to do
that the the other thing that I want to
show you is you can also get templates
from other locations so that if you do
ask new - - template the default
templates are going to come from Amazon
but you can also get templates from
other locations and one of those is
skill templates com so HTTP skill
templates comm slash templates dot Jason
like that and these are templates that
that I created actually and so it's a
list of just basic starter templates
that you can use to to get going so like
the basic starter one is really similar
to the default one that Amazon provides
with the main difference being the
configuration information so in the
skill Jason it's got all of the
configuration information so that when
you deploy this it by just changing this
Jason here you're ready to submit the
skill for certification you would just
want to use your own images of course
and keywords and change all this where
the the default hello world one doesn't
have all of the settings in here and so
you
having to go dig through the
documentation to get the settings but
those are all provided by this one
there's some other templates what we're
gonna do in the next lesson is we're
going to look at diving into one of the
templates modifying the template and
then deploying the template so that is
coming up next
so at this point we've covered
everything that you need to know for the
most part to get your first skill up and
running based on a template and what
we're gonna do in this lesson is recap
and walk through all of the steps and
I'm also going to talk about how you
would go about beta testing skills and
also discuss the process of getting the
skill certified if you want to develop a
skill that's going to be public so we're
gonna start with the Alexus skills kit
CLI and I'm going to use the ask knew
and we're gonna use a template and there
is a template that Amazon provides
called
team lookup and this is like a company
directory skill and so we're gonna use
that one for our example here
and so what after you select the
template that you want to work with and
most of the templates provide if you
look there's like a readme file and you
can go preview like this to read about
the template and there's instructions
for setting the template up and all of
that good stuff the things that you're
gonna want to do you're gonna want to
modify the lambda code and that the goal
of this course was to to not get into
the coding part so much so we are in the
code of course here but we're not really
writing code so much as just finding the
the pieces that need to be edited if
you're working with a template and with
this template and most of the templates
they're very well documented so you can
read the comments and sort of navigate
your way through what needs to be done
in between the comments and the code and
the readme file you should be able to to
navigate easily through this but in this
template the team lookup template there
is most of what you're going to need to
do is just change the references to the
people so they've got the development
team
the Alexa team in here and you can copy
and paste and change this to add your
own team members in here and then
further down there's like the skill name
you can change that and you can change
the welcome messages and pretty much
anything that you see that's in quotes
is something you can change and then I
think they say yeah so this comment here
so caution editing and editing anything
below this line might break your skill
so if you're not comfortable coding yet
you can just avoid changing any of this
stuff down here if if if you are
comfortable coding or you want to start
learning that templates are great
because all the code is provided in all
the templates and so you can come and
look through the code here to get
familiar with what's going on and if you
want to build your own skill you can
either build it directly based on a
template or use some of the code in the
template to build your own custom skills
so a lot of times they for me will act
as a reference you know so you can see
how one skill does something and then
use that in the skill that you're
creating so once you've modified the
lambda code the next thing that you
would do is modify the model here so
assuming that you're not making any
major code changes all you would need to
modify in the model is just the
invocation name so the name that you're
gonna use or the user is going to use to
start the skill up and then the last
thing is the skill Jason here so this is
all of the setting information that's
going to be used in the Alexa Developer
console so this is going to provide the
the name of the skill here and you can
change that and the description the
example phrases so you're gonna want to
go through and edit all this probably
gonna want to provide your own icons and
so you would use 108 by 108 is the small
icon
180 pixels by 108 and then the large
icon is 512 by 512 so you would want to
provide a URL to the icons that you're
gonna use for your skill and then at
this point once you've modified
everything then you would just deploy it
so you would move into the team lookup
folder and just you ask deploy like that
and the CLI is pushing the skittle out
to the developer council and then
building the interaction model which
takes a minute and then it's also going
to deploy the lambda function and well
that's happening let me show you one
other resource that you you might want
to use if you go to Alexa Donna and song
comm and login this is going to provide
you with the equivalent of what you get
in the Alexa or in the echo Alexa
companion app for the Amazon echo so if
you've got an Amazon echo and you've
installed the app for iOS or for Android
this is going to provide the same kind
of functionality so this is where you
would go and search for and enable
skills and also on the home screen where
you would see any card so if in a skill
you can write back information to the
companion app using cards and you can
see this is a card that was written back
earlier when we were working with the
hello world skill and so if you want to
test that you can use the Alexa die
amazon.com to to do that the other thing
worth pointing out in here so if you're
wondering if the name a name that you
want to use for a skill is are even used
you can search here for skills and find
similar skills if you're trying to get
inspiration or if you're trying to make
something that's a little bit different
and
wondering if somebody's already built it
and then over here your skills this is
going to be a list of skills that you
have enabled and then you'll see under
dev skills any skills that are in
development so like here's our team look
up skill here and I would that by now
this is all deployed and it is okay so
the next thing that we would do once the
once the skill is deployed then we're
ready to invite some beta testers and
then once we get the beta testing
process done and we've gotten the
feedback that we need then we're ready
to deploy it to the public skill store
or maybe you just want to deploy it as a
company skill and I'll show you how to
do that so you're gonna do that from in
the developer console here so once you
once you've deployed this skill you can
go back into the developer console and
here you would go to edit for our team
look up and then you're gonna go to so
we we test ourselves while we're in
development but then we also want to
beta test and to do that we would go to
launch here and provide all of the
details for the skill and this is the
stuff that we provided inside the Alexa
dot JSON file so here's like the
reference to the image that are provided
we would change those of course the only
thing that is not provided at least in
this one is the the privacy policy URLs
because these are going to be the URLs
that would point to your privacy policy
of course so I'm gonna do mine and also
to your terms and conditions so you
these are required to need these if
you're going to publish the skill so
you'll need something out there and then
save and continue and then there's some
questions about that you need to answer
for the certification process does the
skill allow users to make purchases or
spend money you want to go through and
answer all these and provide any testing
instructions
if there are any special instructions
that you would want the testers to know
and then save and continue and then the
last step here is to choose how you want
to publish the skill and so you can
publish it publicly in the skill store
and this would make it available for
anybody to enable you can publish it for
just your organization you would need to
have Alexa for business set up to do
that or you can use the beta test option
here and so to beta test you provide
your email and you're gonna be the
administrator so whatever your email is
and then down here you would provide a
list of email addresses for each one of
the beta testers and you can upload a
list in a CSV format where you can enter
individual email addresses separated by
a semicolon and you can have up to 500
of those the email address needs to be
an email address that corresponds with
an Amazon account that is associated
with either you know in an Amazon
developer account or one that's used for
an Amazon echo and then the user or the
beta tester is going to get an email and
in the email there's a link that they
can use to enable the skill and when
they enable the skill it will show up in
their skill list as a skill that's in
development also so these are some
skills I was invited to to test which is
why they're showing up and so if you got
an invitation or a year once your users
get an invitation then they would be
able to test the skill using their
Amazon echo even while it's in
development before it's publicly
available just like you can test it as
the developer so that is the process for
configuring the skill start to finish or
using the template and then configuring
it for beta testing and once you're done
with the beta
testing at this point you just save and
continue to submit the skill for if you
wanted to go public to submit the skill
for certification and the certification
process is pretty quick it's like a
couple of days at the most usually and
if the the skill if there's a problem
with certification the response back
that you get is very detailed in my
experience so they'll tell you exactly
why if it fails certification why it
failed and what you need to do to
resolve that and yeah so that is it at
this point again you have everything
that you need to get your first skill up
and running based on a template and that
is where we're going to to wrap up in
the next video I'm just going to do a
high-level recap and talk about some
resources and some things kind of next
steps that you might want to to take a
look at her that you might be interested
in
congratulations you've completed the
course you should now have a solid
introductory level understanding of how
to build custom Alexa skills and
hopefully you're pretty close to having
your first skill completed from here
you'll want to practice what you've
learned so far and then move on to some
more advanced topics and here are some
suggestions for possible next steps
first head over to GABA lab comm slash
learn there you'll find links to all of
the resources that I mentioned in this
course and you can also subscribe to get
notified when this course is updated or
when I publish a new course I am
planning on publishing more advanced
courses so hopefully if you like this
one and you want to dive deeper you'll
want to check those out too
also Alexa it is constantly evolving and
as a result this course will have
revisions so by subscribing I'll let you
know when those updates happen next
you'll want to check out the dabble at
YouTube channel at youtube.com slash
data lab there you'll find over 50 Alexa
development tutorials that complement
this course you'll also want to go to
github.com slash Alexa to learn more
about the Alexa SDK for node and while
you're there start digging through some
of the code for the sample skills that
Amazon provides and we've also created
some sample code start our templates
that you can use and you'll find those
at skill templates calm well that's it I
really hope that you enjoyed the course
but I also hope that you'll let me know
if there is anything that you think I
can do to make it better
finally if you have any questions about
anything that I've covered don't
hesitate to leave a comment and I'll
respond just as quickly as possible
hey thanks again for taking the course I
hope to see you in a future course